hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode four of my buying and selling
and pay to playay flipping
series uh we're starting off the episode
at about 6.2 mil uh we did really well
last week mostly because there are some
serious price discrepancies and
fluctuations um I think it was because
brutal black dragons had been released
not quite sure but anyway we're going to
start off about 6.2 mil on a side note
I'm going to be gone at a music festival
actually for 4 days so I will be gone
basically until July 3rd so I probably
won't upload for a week whatever too bad
okay so we're going to jump into this
episode here so we're going to start off
with these Dragon arrows p++ uh they had
a 600 GP margin on them and uh they
aren't a lot traded but we'll try buying
a thousand and uh for every one we get
we'll get 600 GP because they were
selling for 2400 uh which is super nice
uh we'll take our last hat so I don't
even know we made another 3K on that so
yeah let's continue on here and next up
I think we're going to do the zor scales
uh we bought them for 159 and sold them
for 157 so there's a 2gp margin on them
pretty standard uh we might actually be
able to afford a get them out of them
this time we should do at least 10K but
we might do yeah we could do 20 actually
so yeah we'll do 20k that's pretty much
the Capo anyway and we'll find at least
one more item to do okay and next up I
think we might do this one do prayer
potion like look at that margin I don't
think it would sell 4,000 but we should
still be able to get 4 500 GP margin on
it now I kind of realized later that I
should just be decanting these in the
full dose potions and then selling them
as the full dose uh it's a kind of neat
way of flipping which I'm going to do in
the next episode I think uh but for now
we're just kind of flipping them
regularly we're just going to buy them
for around 3,100 and we'll hopefully
sell them for 4 or 500 GP
profit and lastly here I think we're
just going to go with the guilded plate
skirt again it's kind of just my go-to
item when I only have 3 or 400k left uh
cuz it's still easy to get a 20 or 30k
margin on it yeah cuz look at it it's
back down again it kind of fluctuates a
good amount but it's sold enough to not
I won't be stuck with it for too long
um so I think we'll put an offer in for
like 289 or something like that I don't
know let's see what it's at yeah maybe
289k and hopefully we can get 30k margin
on that and I will check back when some
of the stuff has
sold so I am back and I was gone for
actually almost two days uh so we did
manage to sell everything we didn't buy
nearly as much as You' expect I mean the
dragon Arrow only got 67 over like a day
and a half uh so we have three days left
in our membership so we're going to just
finish up our membership probably for
this episode so we'll try to as much as
we can um so to see how much money we
made the dragon arrows we only got 67 of
them we got 430 GP margin which is good
uh but we didn't get enough of them to
make a huge profit but we still got 30k
off the dragon arrows uh these Zoro
scales we got 20,000 of them sorry but
we only got 1 GP margin so we only got
20K from those uh the one do prayer
potions we did pretty decent on we got
390 GP margin and just over 100 of those
so about 45k from that and the plate
skirt we just bought one and we got
about 25k from that so all in all we got
like just over 100k so pretty standard
uh but still progressing so that's not
so bad at least we're not going
backwards so let's try this one more
time and uh first up here I think we're
going to do the guilded plate skirt uh
we did get a decent margin on it and
they do buy pretty quickly actually uh
because they were made free to play
there's a much larger market for them
now uh CU before who would really need
the guilded plate skirt if your members
there's way better Alternatives
obviously um um but yeah so we'll try
buying them for 289 again I think and uh
we'll get a couple more this time so if
we do manage to buy all let's see all
seven or eight of them um that'll
actually be quite a bit of profits so
we'll do that first okay and next up I
think we're going to do the Mystic boot
uh it actually has a 2K margin on it and
it's only an 8,000 GP item um so I think
what we're going to do is we're going to
buy 200 of these and then get one more
item um so we'll buy them for about 8110
I think yeah and we'll get 200 of them
and last St here I think we're going to
do the two do prayer potion uh you can
see me in the background buying and
selling it we're buying it for about
6650 and uh we sell it for I think 6,100
so something around that yeah so it has
about a 4 500 GP margin on it which is
pretty good for the price point um again
I should be decanting these but these
clips recorded a couple days ago so in
the future I will probably be doing that
um so we'll go ahead and buy a couple
hundred of these for about
6150 and yeah I will come back when most
of the stuff has bought and sold
okay so everything's sold um The Guild
of plate skirts did not buy at all
unfortunately we raised the price a bit
I forgot to mention we even bought
Dragon arrows but in the end we barely
made anything on it it wasn't really a
good idea and uh we got all the boots
and the potions so on um the things that
kind of mattered here the Mystic boots
uh we actually got nearly a
700700 GP margin and we got about 60 of
the boots we actually got almost even
100k from the uh boots and the the
potions we got about 490 GP margin on
them and we got 100 of those as well um
so we not as well we got 100 of those
and we got about 50k from that so about
150k from just the two items the other
two didn't work at all and yeah so let's
continue on
here so first up we're going to do the
Mystic boots again I think uh CU
actually still has like a 2K margin and
they are traded decently often again
they're used pretty frequently and um
I'm kind of surprised how much money I
make off the Mystic boots because it
doesn't seem like I buy a lot but the
mar is pretty good and it's kind of a
mider item uh so ends up being quite a
bit of money I get so we'll buy 200 of
these and next up I think we're going to
do the two do PA potion again um we we
find some new items that work pretty
well soon uh but these have been going
pretty decent and it still has like a
four or 500 GP margin on these so
there's really no point not to try we'll
just try to get a couple hundred of
these I go for 300 this time and yeah if
we get all 300 we'll get like couple
hundred K so that'll be nice so next up
we're going to try the Rune crossbow and
now this doesn't end up being a very
good idea because cuz I didn't realize
but there is a pretty low buying limit
on the Rune crossbow it's like I think
it's under 100 um units so it's not
really that good for the margin I have
on it but I didn't realize this till
afterwards so we're buying 200 which is
pretty much hopeless um but still we'll
see how many we can get and last up here
I think we're just going to go with the
Rune Arrow has a 2 GP margin on it and
it's pretty much as quick as Z scales
and I can get about 11,000 of the Rune
arrows uh before I hit the bind limit um
but unfortunately I don't know if I have
enough money for that right now no
definitely not so we're going to have to
go with something like 8K and yeah we'll
check back when some of the stuff has
sold okay so everything's sold here and
uh we did pretty good actually um all
the items we made a decent profit on
even the Run cross Bros even though we
didn't buy so many of them we still did
pretty good on them um so we'll start
with the best flip which was definitely
the twoos PA potion uh we got a
465 GP margin I think and we got pretty
about 300 of those which give us about
137k profit which is pretty good uh the
Mystic boots we got actually 1,800 on
each Boot and we got about 38 of them
given a 71k profit the Rune crossbows we
did not get that much on each we only
got 240 GP uh but we did get 70 and they
bought pretty quick so that's 16k for
those and the Rune arrows same thing we
got 16k from them uh we got two more two
GP margin each and we got 8K of them uh
so in total we actually probably got
over 200k from that flip which is a lot
better better than I actually expected
uh so we'll do a couple more of these
okay so we're trying to get some new
items uh in our repertoire so we're
going to try the black dehy these are
traded quite a lot especially since they
released I think um the new dragons they
Dro Dragon black dragon hid so they have
a lot more traded now but that's a
pretty good margin for how quick it is
and what the price is
so10 pretty well uh each hide we buy and
we actually have a decently large cash
attack so we're going to dump a good
amount of money into this um so we'll
buy him for
343 we'll get 1K I guess of
them okay and next up I think we're
going to do the dragon javelins uh these
actually have about a 20 30 GP margin on
them and uh they're traded quite a lot
so we'll give these a try again a kind
of new item we're trying here and I
think we actually might try the poison
version of the Dragon Javelin as well um
we bought him for about 3,200 I think
try to sell the Run Arab accent um and
we're going to sell him for or we'll
have to drop them down a bit cuz they're
not a lot traded but again yes see
that's a huge margin on it um so we'll
go ahead and try to buy some of these I
don't expect to get too many of them
because not many people use them they're
really expensive but we'll buy them for
1620 and we'll get try to get a couple
hundred at
least that's a little ambitious 500 but
we'll see how that goes and last up here
we're going to do the Mystic boot again
it still has a 2K margin on which is
really good we're just going to dump the
rest of our cash in here so I think we
can get just about 50 or so
um yeah we'll do 50 and we'll check back
when this stuff is bought and sold okay
so we have sold the black Dragonites and
we're trying to do some quicker flips
here and I think the Mystic boots and
the javelins have stopped selling uh but
we still made a good amount of profit on
them so far um so the black dehes
crashed a good amount um so we actually
only got 13 GP on each one which isn't
super great for the amount of money
invested at least so we only got 13 GP
times the 786 hides we got so it's only
about 10K from that not super great uh
the Dragon javelins went pretty decent
uh we got a 33 GP margin on them each
and we sold about 1,500 uh so it's 48k
from that so far and the Mystic boots uh
we actually got 1,00 GP margin again
which is great and we got 30 of those
sold so far that's 53k from the boots as
is and we still have to sell um about
half of them back so yeah should be
going for a very nice flip for the boots
so what we just have to do here is just
dump the rest of the items here we'll
see how much the margin's actually
changed um so the dragon javelins have
dropped down a bit so they're down to
about a k each uh so we'll actually be
losing a bit of money on the last bit of
these but overall we'll still have made
at least probably 30
40K um The Mystic boots we'll have to
check again as well I'll just plop in a
high offer here and oh my God those have
crashed a
lot ah don't know if we should wait I
think we're just going to dump him
anyway
so we probably didn't actually make much
on the boot boots because we probably
made 10 20K so that's a little
unfortunate but uh not much you can do
about that we don't really feel like
holding out because we have a good
amount of money left and we have lot
items inventory so we just want to get
rid of these kind of and I think we
might actually do the blue dragon hide
it has about a 35 GP margin on it which
isn't a lot but it is quite heavily
traded and we have a larger cash stack
that we can kind of start doing items
like this um so I mean if we buy a
thousand these 35 GP margin at 35k and
they're they buy and sell really quickly
um so yeah we'll give this a shot we're
going to buy them for about 22 33 and uh
we maybe buy actually 2K if we can
afford it but we might actually try to
diversify the items a
bit no we're going to do
2K okay so the plan here is to do the
lava dragon bones um but pay attention
to what the margins are so 5300 is their
high price and 5155 is the low price so
this isn't necessarily bad um but the
problem comes when I am not paying
attention here and I plop them in for
the high price um and I buy a couple
hundred of them I think I go for 300 and
I know right away as soon as I hit
confirm and they in to buy I'm like well
[__] we bought them for the high price
so of course they all bought right away
and I'm like well [__] um so we
basically are going to just try to cut
our losses here so we'll try to sell
them back for what we bought them for
which would be nice um but I think we're
going to try to yeah oh well whatever it
happens so we shouldn't lose too much on
this so we'll check back when we've
recovered these
bones okay so we have sold pretty much
all the bones and the dehy uh and a
couple of the other things as well um so
the lava dragon bones we actually sold
at about a 42k loss we lost about 40 GP
on each bone so it could have been much
worse for sure we just dumped them out
of there because we didn't want the item
to crash anymore and have it look even
worse um the dehy we got actually 45 GP
profit on each one at least um and we
got about 1400 of those i n us about 62k
um so not the best flip considering you
just goofed it um so whatever we will
continue forward and try to forget that
uh just to mention we are on the last
day of our membership here so we're we
don't want to accidentally get caught
with a bunch of members items um so we
know pretty well when it's going to
expire so we're going to do a couple
more quick flips um but if they aren't
complete and we're just going to pull
them out so we can buy the
membership okay and next up I think
we're going to do the Earth orb it had a
40 GP margin on it and uh we checked ow
buddy and it's traded quite a lot um so
we'll buy for the low price of 1410 and
we'll just buy I think a thousand of
these um no actually we we'll try a
couple thousand and lastly here we're
going to try the blue dragon High
um you can see on the screen there it
has about a 75 GP margin uh which is
pretty nice actually um compared to what
the price usually gives um so we'll buy
as many as we can with the rest of our
money so we'll get about 1,500 I think
and at about 75 GB margin sounds good to
me uh so we'll check back in a couple
hours okay so we have sold the Earth
orbs and the dragon leather um and the
dragon javelins as well so the dragon
javelins we just kind of did a loss on
that section of them probably only 10 to
15K or something um but yeah we're
trying these new items here and they're
not working that great I mean but it's
good to try some new ones cuz we'll find
some great flips eventually um but our
the ones we've been doing more
frequently have been working out better
um but yeah so the Earth orbs we got a
40 GP margin on them which is pretty
good but we only got 770 of them so we
got both 31k from the earth orbs uh the
blue dehy crashed a bit but we still got
12 GP margin uh at we bought about, 1500
of them so that's 18K from that so not
super great but uh we didn't lose any
money at least uh which is always a
positive so let's go ahead and we
probably have time for one more flip
before my membership expires uh so I
think we're going to try the Redwood log
it actually has a 45 GP margin and it's
a pretty brand new item so there's a lot
traded uh they settle down a bit though
because they used to be much more
expensive um so I think we're going to
dump the majority of our money in here
we're going to buy I think two or 3K of
the logs um and yeah so I hope this
should work I'm kind of confident
because the Redwood
logs uh are traded a lot at the same
time though I don't know who's actually
buying these things they're not that
useful a lot of people are chopping them
for sure uh but we'll give it a try
we'll buy 4,000 and hopefully we can
keep the 45 GP margin and I think we're
going to lastly try the Run Aros um they
have a 3 GP margin on them and we should
have enough money to hit the bind limit
uh which is
11,000 um so we'll buy him for 127 and I
think we're going to put in for the
buying limit or maybe 10K but close
enough has nice even amount at least um
so we'll check back when some of the
stuff has sold and I think then we're
going to renew our
membership okay so there we are we have
one day left in our membership we're
going to go renew it right now I believe
uh first we're just going to check on
the last flips we did um so again kind
of mediocre realistically uh the Rune
arrows I mean we did get a 2gp margin on
them um which is okay it's pretty decent
um so we got 20K from the Run Aros since
we had bought 10 of them the Redwoods we
did not manage to buy many at all we
only got 40 or 245 sorry and uh we sold
them for a 45 GP margin but that's still
only like 11k profit um so not super
great at the end there but uh I mean
overall in the episode we still made
about
700k um I mean it's not bad but I mean
we did have a lot more money so we
should have been able to profit more so
we're going to try some different items
next time um but we'll buy the bond here
um we're going to just plop in for 296
and yep and we bought it right away
perfect so we have the bond renewed for
another 14 days um so if you kind of
look at it now we're at 4 mil whereas
last time we started at 2.5 mil so we
are progressing we're not going
backwards by any means here and uh next
episode I have some new techniques I'm
going to try that uh should help profit
us quite a bit and hopefully uh buying
the bonds won't actually be a huge chunk
of our cash pretty soon um yeah so
thanks for tuning in guys I will see you
guys in episode five and yeah if you
enjoyed hit that subscribe button or if
you liked it just h hit that like button
all right I will see you guys next time
[Music]